Brooklyn Heights in the house oh thanks
for coming on et Canada Prize oh my god
it's my pleasure you are fabulous thank
you
how much fun him you are thought I am
fabulous we're gonna talk about RuPaul
but I want to I want to take it back a
bit because I know you were a dancer for
a very long time and we're seeing that
throughout the season yeah so where did
your love of dance come from I started
dancing very late I was one of those
kids I didn't really have a hobby I did
gymnastics when I was like little and
then I stopped and I didn't really have
anything to do like an after-school
activity so I convinced my parents to
put me in dance class and I did jazz for
like a year like one hour a week Wow and
then a friend of mine I was at ESA a
topical School of the Arts hey shout out
shout out I was there for musical
theater which is really funny cuz I
cannot sing at all I somehow got in
anyway so I was there and a friend of
mine who was a dance major she was like
I'm going down to the National Ballet
School of Canada to audition for their
summer program you should come and I was
like why not that sounds like a great
idea I had done like maybe ten ballet
classes alright at that point I was 15
years old so I went with my mom and she
was like you're not gonna get in but
sure she literally was like you're not
gonna get in supportive parents so I
went and I got in that's incredible yeah
and that that's just it was a complete
freak thing I guess they saw the
potential cuz I had no training and I
spent the next five years at the
National Ballet School of Canada right
here in Toronto and then I went on to
dance in South Africa for a couple years
and then I went on to dance in New York
with Bali Trocadero not as incredible
yeah just taking a chance like that has
probably changed your lives yeah my
whole life everything in my life has
kind of happened very randomly like all
the big things like that getting into
pageantry getting into drag it's all
been very like a random and it just kind
of like happened what was the first time
you put on drag do you remember
well like I was that kid I was always
and my mom I said yeah you can see
tanner pride like the cool station yeah
yeah I was always said my mom's like
close and like there's pictures of me as
a kid with like a blanket wrapped around
my head as a wig so I was always
fabulous so I've kind of been doing drag
my whole life the first time I ever like
went out in drag was so cliche
Halloween when I was like 19 for a
friend's birthday and we all got dressed
up but from that first time when you saw
yourself in drag we're you like I'm
really enjoying this I loved it I well
I've always loved everything feminine
like even I just I love dolls I love
women's clothes even in Bali I never
cared about being a male ballet dancer I
just wanted to be the girl so like I
always have just loved everything
feminine so it's just kind of like it
was natural and it felt natural for me
you've been performing in Toronto in
drag for such a long time and we have
some visuals now you're not showing yes
we are showing there everyone's watching
them right now I'm gonna hide under my
chair does it feel amazing to come back
to Toronto and now as Brooklyn Heights
from RuPaul's Drag Race go back to these
clubs and bars you played and went -
yeah many years ago I mean this was like
my home this is where I learned how to
be a drag queen how to really perform on
stage because I mean a lot of people
don't know drag in Toronto is so
different from anywhere else I've done
it because we do so much more of it here
like literally just the quantity that
drag queens have to do here and it's a
lot of work and he's girls worked so
hard and I've been there and I really
credit that to like my success as a drag
queen because I learned you just learnt
you got to do it so much that you really
learn what works and what doesn't work
so it's incredible coming back here and
I so many of my friends are up here like
some of these girls are my sisters I'm
like really good friends so it's just
cool to got to come up and be like
[Laughter]
[Music]
never fear the queen of the north is
here well we love that you're our queen
of the north it is so amazing to have
Canada represented on a show like
RuPaul's Drag Race that is globally a
massive show yeah what kind of weight
does that carry for you to be the very
first Queen from Canada on that show
it's a lot of pressure honestly I mean
it's a such an honor and I'm so happy
that I'm able to represent a country it
feels like I'm at the Olympics yeah like
it's like team gets like real team
Canada like I'm the only person there
representing an entire country and it's
it's amazing
definitely a lot of pressure but I'm
okay
I work well under pressure are there
certain Queens that from past seasons
you've maybe looked up to oh my god many
I mean I think some of the Queens I look
up to the most Roxxxy Andrews she's just
like the best drag queen in the world
like she just does everything herself
and it's Jesus like but I think of a
drag queen and like Roxxxy Andrews I
love her I love shangela and Alyssa just
because they're they're amazing drag
queens and they're amazing entertainers
but their work ethic like they're they
hustle yeah like and that's kind of what
I want to be like I love I love detox
she's a good friend of mine and again
just heard the fact that she was on the
season on the show like five years ago
and she's still so relevant and she has
that longevity I want that staying power
in longevity and Chad Michaels Chad
Michaels is like one of my fairy
godmothers the experience of being in
that environment of RuPaul's Drag Race
it's not an easy one and like reality TV
in general is not easy and I don't think
people or fans of the show understand
that no do you feel like so far on your
time in the show we've been able to see
the real Brooklyn Heights yeah I mean my
thing is I'm I'm quite quiet at first
like especially when you you're put in
this you're shoved in a room with 15
other drag queens everyone has huge egos
huge personalities everyone's excited
the adrenaline is going everyone's being
loud and I'm just not that person like
it takes me a minute to warm up to
people and kind of get to know them
before I start reading the dog bed of
them yeah so it just yeah you're seeing
me warm up like it just takes me a
minute yeah it takes me a minute to get
there I like to like feel people out
before I like jump right in the fan base
of this show there I mean
bass is massive but something that I'm
finding and I don't love is there's a
lot of hate that hop eggs and like this
first show that is all about love yeah
it's all about love I want the fans to
stop that oh agree you can have a
favorite Queen everybody's allowed to
their opinion
yeah but death threats and those types
of things are not cool how are you
dealing with the haters because as
fabulous as you are on the show I'm sure
you also get hate yeah well I honestly
like know T like knock on wood I really
haven't gotten a lot of hate sorry which
I'm so thankful for there's been like
little things here there but I'm just
like yeah block a lot of people don't
understand what a stressful environment
like when we're filming this we are
working long days we're away from our
families were cut off from the world and
we're it's pressure because we've all
worked so hard to be there and then so
of course we're gonna say things we
don't mean of course we're gonna fly off
the handle that's also what they want
because they're making a reality TV show
and no shade I mean that's what you have
to do to get good TV but people just
need to understand that we're all human
beings and we all kind of pop off once
in a while
so let's spread love yes love love
everyone say love speaking of love I
need you to spill some tea right here on
et Canada pride what is the deal with
you and Van G are we dating
are we dating are we are we dating well
we can you have a boyfriend I do have a
bad date we cannot date no but what is
happening with you and banjee because
this is a huge storyline and truth be
told it is amazing I've been waiting 11
seasons to see two people I can see the
connection between you two he's so cute
oh my god I just love like I was
watching him at the screening party last
night it he's just so like he just makes
me laugh but he's like his little voice
it talks like that's I love when he
narrates himself going down the runway
like a Victoria's Secret Angel and I'm
stopped it and I look good and then he's
like this like beautiful like he's
moment of its like boys it's comfy got
him dour he's gold he's um Vangie is
amazing and yeah we've gotten really
close and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
spoil anything because the season is not
over yet
yeah that's fine but you guys
or you guys are kissing we're kissing
you're kissing I'm just touching and
kissing damn right you're getting those
cookies I am getting those cookies
[Music]
Brooke was a good friend of mine we have
a crush on each other me and Angie have
a crush on each other
I think Vangie is really cute and we're
just getting to know each other it's
real fresh out the wind your looks on
this season have been out of this world
thank you like insane love love love
Brooklyn Heights how do you really feel
about me would have been some of your
favorite looks that we've seen so far
because orange alert I believe was the
one run Rock of my own my my um yeah um
my own favorite looks orange alert for
sure I love that one I loved I loved my
detox bond my first one that was really
good the only one I didn't really like I
didn't hate it but I wasn't like really
careful where's my fringe one which I
know people liked but I was just that
was the flowers yeah it was gorgeous it
was fine just for me the thing people
don't understand they're like why wasn't
there more fringe on there I'm like
because that frit it wasn't fringe it
was like daisy chains so when you walk
they would twirl around each other and
you could not get them untangled who do
you think right now moving forward is
your toughest competition in the series
I think Evie Evie's really real I love
Evie I love Evie because she's so
different than me I just I think it's
really cool she is such a cool
she's so conceptual and she's so
intelligent and she's so 100% herself
and she just kind of says exactly what's
on her mind at all times
yeah girl but when are you gonna apply
that to the challenges cuz that's what's
gonna keep you out of the bottom I will
tell you this don't try me right now
plastique obviously it's just prettier
than me
I don't know if that's true I thought
sure 21 I just wanna like tribals are
great this is like the outfit for two I
just want to like suck like the youth
out of her is there somebody that you
think needs to step there up in the
competition so you can't say I can I
mean
okay I know the power of a wig you could
say who's in danger girl who in dangers
and danger girl
I think sugars and a little bit of
danger I mean that she hasn't had a
great couple weeks um especially after
this last episode so I would like to see
her like step it up cuz she's sickening
if you win the competition there is a
prize of $100,000 is what are you gonna
do with that money do you have plans for
that I do actually
um I'm in a really wonderful position
with this just in drag race in general
because you make a lot more money when
you're on TV doing what you do so I'm
already making great money so I've been
thinking a lot about it and I would
really like to donate it all to charity
Wow
honestly that's what I would like to do
with it I mean there's so many great
organizations and I want to get back I
want to use this to give back I would
love to use it for Canadian charities
and there's lots of amazing LGBTQ
charities up here that could use help
and I would love to be able to support
them that's a beautiful idea I love that
you said that well we're all so excited
and we're all so proud and you are you
are such a great representative of
Canada on the show thank you I'm so I
can't even tell you what it means to be
able to be able to represent a country
yeah like it's just amazing and I really
hope this somehow opens the doors for
more Canadian queens to be able to get
on the show
well congratulations thank you for
hanging with me on anything this is so
much fun it was fun and when you win
yeah you're gonna come back absolutely
I'll come back if I don't win